des conditions de circulation très
difficiles sont annoncées demain matin à
tour oui il est recommandé d'entrer dans
la ville avant 8h45 car après les choses
sérieuses commencent le désamorçage
d'une bombe de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale située sous le pont com à
Fondette une manœuvre qui va nécessiter
la fermeture de plusieurs axes dont le
périphérique de tour Clémence
d'osque attention route barré aux
alentours du ponsincom ce jeudi 12
octobre les zones les plus proches de de
l'opération de déminage devront être
évacué pour des raisons de sécurité cela
concerne aussi bien les habitations que
les commerces l'établissement devra tout
simplement fermer ses portes entre 8h30
le matin et 15h l'après-midi donc perdre
de chiffre d'affaires mes salariés à
payer les charges qui bien sûr se fa
suspendu donc du
bonheur pour se rendre au travail les
automobilistes concernés devront s'armer
de patience entre sa cire surloire et la
riche la rocate sera fermée desès 8h45
aux abords de l'agglomération ça risque
de bouchonner moi directement non je ne
suis pas concerné mais les oui j'ai de
la famille qui travaille et qui donc va
devoir faire un détour je suis à l'ITS
l'école de VS et du coup le matin je
dois partir presque 1 heure en avance
déjà alors que j'habite pas loin et du
coup là je sais pas demain ça va être
super compliqué sûrement falloir faire
des grands détours parler bas de sainir
monter un peu dans les petites dans les
petites routes donc prévoir le trajet
bien en avance la préfecture d'indréloir
recommande de différer ses déplacement
dans le périmètre de sécurité pas de
circulation entre la porte de tour et la
rue du Docteur chaôumier près de La
Riche entre saincir et Fondette une
partie des quais de la guinière et du
quai des maisons blanches seront barré
de même que la rue des autroches
toujours dans cette zone les quais de la
Loire seront évidemment inaccessibles au
piétons et au vélo la bombe de 500 kg
sera neutralisé avant d'être évacué par
hélicoptère l'opération devrait
s'achever dans
l'après-midi